John Carpenter's Halloween gave birth to
the modern slasher film establishing
virtually every one of the genres tropes
and dramatically announcing its director
as a major new talent but even though
you've seen it a dozen times there's a
lot you might not know about one of the
greatest and most influential horror
films ever made independent feature it's
now a classic horror film that paved the
way for everything that came after
but Halloween wasn't exactly a major
production the film was the brainchild
of producer Irwin Yablonski land ability
to innovate on a tight budget you
Blondes his idea was simple enough ah
movie about babysitters in jeopardy
being terrorized and we'll do it all in
one night in fact early in
pre-production the project had the
working title the babysitter murders
speaking with Entertainment Weekly
Carpenter remembered I was finishing
directing a TV movie called someone's
watching me when Earl enya blonds called
and said why don't we set it on
Halloween night in fact why don't we
call it Halloween Carpenter came up with
the idea of the small town with a dark
secret that's revisited on Halloween
night he and Debra hill wrote the script
as he'll explained to Fangoria we wrote
the whole thing in three weeks then we
just had to find the right actors
casting Laurie especially important was
casting the part of Laurie Strode the
movies heroine Tommy Lee Wallace
carpenters friend and one of the film's
editors explained a consequence of sound
this was a time that women were
asserting their rights like never before
and Deborah was a very assertive woman
no way she was going to have a weeping
violet type as her heroine carpenter who
didn't watch television had never seen
Jamie Lee Curtis work on the series
operation petticoat
but Hill was convinced she'd be perfect
for the role one small detail was all it
took to convince carpenter Curtis also
happened to be the daughter of Janet Lee
perhaps the original scream queen whose
shower had been rudely interrupted in
the 1960 classic psycho pulling out all
the tricks the film was shot with a
$320,000 budget if it doesn't look
particularly low-budget it's because
Carpenter was a master at making
something from nothing as there was no
room in the budget for a costume
department the entire cast wardrobe was
purchased on the cheap at local
department stores Michael Myers mask was
crafted from a repurposed William
Shatner mask purchased from a local
costume store for a dollar 98 and
painted white also enabling them to keep
the budget
check the filming location for the Myers
house was an abandoned property owned by
a church and although the film was shot
in Pasadena California it was set in
Illinois so carpenter evokes the feel of
autumn in the Midwest by using the same
several trash bags full of painted
leaves for only exterior scenes
scattering them around whatever street
they were currently shooting on only to
collect them all to be reused in the
next shot the minimalist aesthetic
carried over to post-production
Carpenter wrote the film's classic theme
in only an hour and scored the entire
film himself in just three days working
for peanuts another way to keep the
budget low was to pay very little as the
biggest name in the cast Donald
Pleasence got a flat fee of $20,000
while a little-known star Kurtis
received only $8,000 carpenter's buddy
Nick Cassell was paid the princely sum
of $25 per day to portray the shape as
Michael Myers is called in the credits
and carpenter himself took only $10,000
plus a small percentage of the film's
profits which ended up working out for
him he said I can't remember exactly how
much money I made off the film I do
remember getting one check for over a
million dollars that wasn't bad limited
release Halloween debuted on October
25th 1978
in a single City Kansas City Missouri as
the bus started to grow national critics
started paying attention the great Roger
Ebert concluded his sparkling review
with a warning that should have had any
horror fans sprinting out the door to
buy tickets I'd like to be clear about
this
if you don't want to have a really
terrifying experience don't see
Halloween the film went on to gross in
astonishing 47 million dollars raining
for over a decade as the most profitable
independent film ever made
not as gory as you think despite how you
might remember it
Halloween includes virtually no on
screen gore carpenter's expert use of
slowly building tension spooky imagery
and perfectly deployed jump scares left
audiences with the impression that what
they had just seen must have been crazy
violent in order to be that disturbing
but that wasn't carpenters take I wanted
something deadly simple and something
that would just eat a little bit Hill
alluded to this in production notes for
1981 s Halloween to sane people don't
seem to realize that we showed next to
no blood in the first picture you think
you're seeing a lot more than we're
showing you the almost anthology
carpenter and he'll never envision
even a single sequel let alone a
franchise carpenter explained a deadline
I didn't think there was any more story
and I didn't want to do it again instead
of finding ways to bring Michael Myers
back carpenter and Hill had the idea to
tell a different story with each new
Halloween film making it an ongoing
horror anthology series Halloween Sue's
tepid box office convinced producers to
give it a shot and the result 1982's
Halloween 3 season of the witch
instantly polarized horror fans
everywhere many fans wanted Michael
Myers back and they got their wish six
years later
although the sequels and rebooted series
that follow provided mostly diminishing
returns with one exception
Halloween h2o 20 years later ignored
previous sequels and served as a direct
sequel to Halloween - ironically
Halloween is set to receive the same
retcon treatment again the Halloween
reboot scheduled for 2018 will serve as
a direct sequel to the original with
carpenters serving as executive producer
and providing the score and Jamie Lee
Curtis returning to play Laurie Strode
one more time
[Music]